you grew up where in california berkeley
california okay yeah it's like when
lennon and mccartney meet really young
you meet the two guys who you feel
comedically you're in tune with kiva and
yourma yes and you're just funny guys
together
yeah like you make each other laugh yeah
our group of friends was actually like
11 or 12 dudes and then we were just the
three that kept going now lauren was
smart he recognized that you
kind of needed your two buddies yeah to
be with you on the show yeah like
because you got hired he felt he seems
to be really comforted by these two
characters that he works with and he was
nice enough to hire them too yeah crazy
which is kind of rare right like very
rare we wrote a writing packet together
right so the writing packet was
submitted as all three of us in case
they just wanted us as writers
and then the second time i auditioned
yorma also auditioned so were you guys
hired to do digital shorts was that the
idea was lauren thinking that not
specifically in the beginning what
happened was after we were hired uh
kevin yore went off and shot something
on their own while i was out of town or
something and we showed it to them and
we were like hey would you ever air this
we just made it yeah and they said we
have so much cast right now
we have to have the cast in it but if
you can do stuff like this with casts
right shorts yeah exactly so then
we tried it again and it was this thing
called lettuce that was the first
digital short that ever aired right and
then we made another one and that's
where you just eat lettuce right yeah
it's me and will forte having a really
dramatic conversation and then taking
huge bites of lettuce and spitting all
over each other yeah that's pretty
gnarly
and they liked it they liked it it aired
and we were like holy [ __ ] this just
aired the thing we made for no money uh
and then basically the next one was the
narnia rap lazy sunday and that went
very and that thing went viral went big
it was also just
youtube wasn't a known thing yet yeah
and so the timing was really really good
see that brought a lot of people to
saturday night live because up until
then the only way you really saw
saturday live was on tv and we know like
you brought them sort of into the
digital age where people watch stuff
online and get turned on to saturday
night live yeah and i think lauren would
credit you with that right i think
he i think everyone would say that that
video was the first snl one to be viral
viral but i think if you know if cowbell
had been a few years later it would have
been cowbell it was just people didn't
have the streaming capability yet yeah
the the one that i really love that you
guys did on saturday night live i mean
everyone knows dick in a box with uh
justin timberlake but the one i love is
where you know you kind of parody rap
songs where every rapper for some
[ __ ] reason has to be on a yacht
and it was such a funny it was such a
funny observation you shot you shot like
a rap video in miami
[Music]
it's really weird like those digital
shorts when i think about it not
everybody gets to do those like right
yeah okay i was thinking like mr bill
back in the day of belushi and acrobat
right on saturday night and maybe
ambiguously gay duo michael smeigle was
doing that but not a lot of guys get
their own film segments you know right
well albert brooks was the very
beginning and albert brooks of course
yeah and uh adam mckay did him for a
while before we were there yeah so you
kind of brought that back too right yeah
yeah and you know in a weird way too
like justin timberlake you made him a
[ __ ] breakout star in comedy if you
think about it because of dick in a box
right did you write that uh yeah meek
even your wrote it were you worried that
he wouldn't do it because i mean you
know it is sort of racy even for
saturday night live well i will say
dick in a box was really big but he had
posted once before and killed yeah he's
good at it he's really good he was
already kind of on fire yeah he did like
very good talk show which we loved right
but when we first met with him we were
like what are we gonna do with this guy
i'm not sure like we were still so new
we didn't understand how to face it but
we sort of bonded over that we all loved
early 90s r b music is it hard to pitch
dick in a box because conceptually not
you know a lot of artists are worried
about their reputation yeah did he went
for it immediately and in fact we're
comedians so we were like i don't know
this might be stupid and i pitched him
the idea and he was like that's great
that's going to be a hit and we were
like really yeah we didn't even know
that yeah because it's such a fine line
some stuff is so [ __ ] dumb you don't
know if the audience is going to get it
you take some swings and have some
whiffs